ah
[Música]
les voy a decir algo
saben
[Música]
esta foto de cuando es
este día fue el día que cante con mi
gente más admirada con los que habían
sido mis referentes de toda la vida en
un teatro bellísimo acompañados por una
orquesta sinfónica con coro ya cuando el
director musical me llamó se me había
puesto la piel de gallina y en un
momento de la charla él me dijo sabes
quiénes van a ser tus compañeras
la verdad que no
cuando me dijo se me cayó la mandíbula
pero literal le juro se me cayó la
mandíbula
lo que todos ustedes no saben es todo lo
que tuvo que pasar para llegar hasta acá
todo comenzó cuando tenía cuatro años yo
me acuerdo mis papás siempre hicieron
música como un hobby no mamá tocaba el
acordeón y mi papá tocaba el bajo y
estudiaba órgano y me acuerdo de esa
tarde pero como si fuese ayer él estaba
tocando como todos los días las mismas
piezas una y otra vez
y esta vez ya se equivoca no pasaron ni
dos segundos e iba esta política y le
dice no no no no te equivocaste entonces
de agarra los saca de la banqueta y con
la manita le toca la melodía tal cual
era
que hicieran ellos unos días después
llamaron a unos músicos amigos para que
vayan a casa y eso me propusieron hacer
un juego me decían bueno vos ponete de
espaldas al órgano nosotros te vamos a
tocar una nota cual sea y vos sin mirar
nos tenés que decir que no te ves pero
podría hacer cualquier nota o se podía
hacer desde la más aguda hasta la más
grave pasando por los cinco registros
que tiene el órgano no
y yo me acuerdo que yo diciendo la
sostenido re bemol dos fa
y ellos soles en este momento les puedo
decir que sé que acertaba todo porque
ellos se reían a carcajadas venía me
abrazaba me daban besos me festejaban un
montón y después me daban flan citó
porque en ese momento en el puesto que
más me gustaba
y así comenzó todo como un juego mi papá
tuvo la buena idea de armar un grupo
integrados por padres y sus hijos y me
acuerdo que ensayamos más así un poco en
familia todos los domingos por la mañana
en el garaje de mi abuelo
y no pasó mucho tiempo hasta que
decidieron enviarme a estudiar
profesionalmente canto y piano
pero la enseñanza de antes era como un
poquito distinta a como es hoy poquito
yo me acuerdo de estar sentada al lado
de la profesora de piano y cuando me
equivocaba sacaba una birome de
correctivo en los deditos
y esa es una de las tantas cosas que
tengo para contarles tengo muchísimos
ejemplos la verdad que desde el vamos lo
viví con muchísima responsabilidad
tanta tanta responsabilidad que
estudiaba minuciosamente para cada
ensayo
me levantaba y tomaba una cucharada de
miel en ayunas todos los días no gritaba
por supuesto y por recomendación de una
profesora de canto saben que no hacía
que es impensable para un chico para una
nena
no tomaba helado no tomaba helado pero
imagínate
y de la mano de todo ese esfuerzo
todo fue creciendo me suma un coro
infantil con ese coro grabamos un disco
tocamos en teatros en anfiteatros y a
parecíamos casi diariamente en
televisión
lo que ustedes
nunca ven porque nosotros nos hacemos
especialistas en eso tengo que admitirlo
es todo lo que sube con nosotros al
escenario
inevitablemente todo lo que pasa debajo
de él pero nos sigue a todos lados
mi carrera crecía
y mi hermana se moría
mi hermana mayor nació con anoxia
cerebral por una falencia médica
y estuvo en estado vegetativo
los 16 años que consiguió vivir
si bien en mi casa se vivió todo con
muchísimo amor y con mucha contención
pero era una realidad muy distinta a la
que veíamos o por lo menos la que
veíamos en otras familias cercanas a
nosotros nos destruyó
fue en este contexto
que recibo la propuesta para iniciar una
carrera como solista
teniendo solamente 11 años
para lanzar mi imagen me habían
propuesto
grabar un spot publicitario que
aparecería en los medios y fue un tiempo
de muchísima actividad de estar
permanentemente en rada de televisión y
una vorágine porque realmente
estaba de repente en la escuela
estudiando con los compañeritos y de
repente estaba en una reunión con
adultos que ni siquiera conocía muy bien
con un representante del que había sido
el sello rca que nos proponía hacer un
disco solista
bueno finalmente
cuando hago mi debut en las dos fechas
que estaban pautadas en un teatro
lo hice tristísima porque ya sabía que
se terminaba todo
mis papás habían hablado conmigo días
antes nada más
y me dijeron qué
que iba a dejar de cantar por lo menos
por un tiempo
pero que iba a dejar de cantar porque
ellos querían que me ponga a tono con la
escuela porque querían que tenga una
infancia más normal y principalmente
porque ellos me querían proteger y me
querían preservar era muy chiquita
si yo les cuento
que llegue después de esta segunda
función a mi casa
sintiendo un vacío
y me largué a llorar y no pare durante
un mes
creo que es poco
fue increíble porque
sentía viste viste cuando sentís que
alguien te agarra la garganta y te la
aprieta
y no no sentía que no podía no podía
decir no
una angustia permanente
y fui diagnosticada con depresión y si y
si era un combo entre el fallecimiento
muy reciente de mi hermana y de la cual
bueno mamá no se recuperó nunca más
y que yo no tenía ya ese canal de
expresión eso que me conectaba con el
mundo ya no estaba
y ustedes dirán volvió a cantar
[Música]
de a poquito una fecha al año otra fecha
despacito despacito
con muchas inseguridades con mucha
angustia
y finalmente los años pasaron y cuando
ya estaba en la universidad
es una cosa increíble se activó un botón
del azar tengo que estudiar
todo y tengo que hacer todo y ese hacer
hacer hacer en realidad era el hacer
hacer por ese stop ese parate que había
tenido en aquel momento y sentía que
necesitaba recuperar todo el tiempo
perdido
entonces fue una locura pero más o menos
como para graficarlo es lo que pasaba en
ese momento
los traigo conmigo a un solo fin de
semana ubiquémonos de jueves a domingo
el jueves me iba a cantar una peña
folklórica empezaba ahora no sale no
cita
el viernes al día siguiente me iba a
cantar tango
ya sé que estoy bien está bien está bien
da
[Música]
al día siguiente el sábado me iba a
tocar teclados con una banda de rock and
roll a un boliche no sé por qué
imaginé que
y al día siguiente el domingo
terminaba así me iba a ser un concierto
lírico a un lugar
qué locura
de edad
ensalada una ensalada y saben las veces
que me pasó que venía alguien del
público y me decía muy lindo este pero
yo cuando te vine a ver cantar vine
porque sabía que vos cantaba tango o mis
besos o cualquier otra cosa
claro los tenía mareados y claro como no
lo voy a tener mareado si yo estaba
perdida estaba que soy femenina que
querés tengo los gemelos ahí en
contraposición
y ahí empezó la cantinela todos mis
allegados empezaron a decirme que tenía
que escuchar los proyectos de otros
artistas que seguían una línea
determinada y un género determinado y
que no tenía estilo que no sé que
después cuando iba a presentarles mi
material a algunos periodistas
que no tenía una identidad que lo miro
demasiado ecléctico pero periodista
nunca se perdieron ustedes no se
perdieron
y nos pasa a todos y si yo me enojaba me
enojaba de una manera me molestaba pero
me molestaba porque tenían razón
tenían razón sí sí sí
y bueno y vieron cuando uno está así de
desconectado ese nivel de conexión
qué pasa qué pasa pasa qué
me queda manga pero muda muda muda pasto
terrible pero aparte lo insólito de esto
era que cuatro horas antes de reloj te
juro que de reloj de cada función me
quedaba muda fue
ahora
más vale yo me daba cuenta que era una
resistencia psicológica emocional que
tenía que no tenían las herramientas
para hacerlo ahora después de mucho
tiempo de análisis
psicólogos y psiquiatras precedentes que
eso se llama
autoboicot
y bueno eso es tema de otra charla ter
ahora en ese momento que les cuento no
tenía herramientas
ustedes a ver díganme por ejemplo a
ustedes los contratan para cantar en
algún lugar y cuatro horas antes se
quedan mudos que hacen
qué hacen
obvio y va a cantar igual
horrible salía pero no importa yo iba
porque vamos a remontarnos un poquito
atrás por mi historia
yo
era la hija sana
la hija que tenía el talento la que
tenían las posibilidades
y creen que yo le iba a dar chance al
error que le iba a dar oportunidad a
pagar a parar de cantar de nuevo de
ninguna manera
lamentablemente yo había aprendido
a trabajar bajo la adversidad si tenía
adversidad me potencia y si algo me
cuesta allá voy y voy doble
toco
dios mío
y así y así estuve un montón de tiempo
hasta que un fin de semana
me senté relajada a ver vídeos
y empecé a ver vídeos de mi infancia de
cuando yo empezaba a cantar y tuve una
revelación
me asombré
pero qué está haciendo esta nena pero
mira lo que está haciendo esta nena
ay por favor claro tiene eso tiene tiene
eso que no no eso que no se esfuerza eso
es lo que simplemente es que fluya
claro
aldana la adulta se desconectó de eso y
no no pero para sí la nena lo tenía la
adulta en algún lado lo tiene que tener
para para para para para
y saca
porque la voz
sale hacia afuera
antes
pero el viaje el viaje es hacia adentro
todo
hay que cantar es mi mano alzada y
fuerte
[Música]
y en este corazón
se reencontró con algo
el pecho se abrió de par en par
y el corazón redescubrió la entrega
la entrega
ahora ahora cada vez que subo
el único requisito
antes de cantar
es ese
es estar abierta y dar lo mejor de mí
y principalmente
soltar los a ustedes
con la mirada
que muchas veces son el peso y que son
el orgullo más enorme que podemos tener
nosotros los que estamos de este lado
y dejé
de esperar
entendí que si yo estoy acá
estoy con el propósito únicamente
de dar de darles todo de entregarles
todo
por eso mi regalo para ustedes hoy es
no será tan fácil
ya sé qué pasa
no será tan simple
como abrir el pecho
y
sacarla
una cuchillada
del amor
quien di
dijo que todo está perdido
yo vengo a ofrecer
[Música]
mi corazón
[Aplausos]
[Música]